to present the directing Awards we have
an actor who has just completed
directing his first picture the duke of
the box office mr. John Wayne
do what lets you to become a director
the need for self-expression or a new
outlet for artistic endeavor no I want
to share with my name of Lee well who
was your star I was your producer I was
you don't need a chair you need a couch
a couch and that fella to talk to
on the set the director is the captain
of the ship commanding general the
signal calling quarterback the wagon
master the father figure to make his
picture he must have patience authority
taste drive selectivity knowledge and
guts it also helps if he has a little
talent too now here are the fine
extremely talented gentlemen who were
nominated for the best achievement in
directing for the past year William
wider for Ben Hur George Stevens for the
Diary of Anne Frank Fred Zinnemann
for the nuns story Jack Clayton for room
at the top and Billy Wilder for some
like it hot may I dare open the yellow
envelope please Ben Hur
but deepest appreciation to Sam's
embolus and Giovanni for their
confidence and to my fellow members of
the Academy for this
next we meet a man we meet a man who
reached the heights while standing in
his bare feet the man who discovered the
first shortcut through the pass here to
present the best picture award is the
gentleman who invented the horse mr.
Gary Cooper
come on I'm pretty excited about this
Bob I need all the help I can get when
you cooperate yep what can I do for you
coop please I've walked off the stage so
many times tonight I feel like Jack Paar
before we discover the name of the best
motion picture of the past year here are
some scenes from the five nominated
films the nominated pictures are anatomy
of murder Otto Preminger Columbia Otto
Preminger producer Ben Hur metrical and
Mayor Sam symbolism producing the Diary
of Anne Frank
20th Century Fox George Stevens producer
the nuns story Warner Brothers Henry
blankie producer and room at the top
Romulus films John and James wolf
producers and now the winner Ben Hur Sam
Zimbalist
producer of ben-hur
leading the award for mr. Sam Zimbalist
is mrs. Sam symbolic
I believe my husband would have said you
that then her is the some work and
talent of many people and that he would
accept this award gratitude for all of
them for himself I think those of you
whose whole lives have been spent as my
husband's was making films will know in
your own thoughts what this moment would
have meant to him as a symbol of Sam's
endless
I am very probably - thank you
well ladies and gentlemen about Knox
City it's all over but the sniveling
before we go out to the press tent to
see the winners I must remind you that
our program tonight was sponsored by the
motion picture industry distributors of
such quality products as Marilyn Monroe
Jayne Mansfield and Gina Lollobrigida
better things for better living through
crazy chemistry tonight you've seen
Hollywood Barrett starts that's all
we're allowed to show on television and
the psychiatrist for tonight's losers
were flown here by TWA in a few hours
the winners will be flying by themselves
for the winners there will be a giant
victory celebration in the Grand
Ballroom of the Hilton Hotel the rest of
us will gather in the monoxide room of
the Price Waterhouse garage you've been
a wonderful audience intelligent
generous and enthusiastic where were you
during aliased Jesse James
oh well let's watch the Press print and
Robert Ryan a member the Academy's Board
of Governors
here's another member of the board
governor's mr. Wendell Florrick
thank you Bob the confusion in the
background here is the first aftermath
of the 32nd annual Academy Awards
photographers reporters in the world
interviewing headline news in every
country where the motion picture is
still in audiences greatest
entertainment another chapter in the
history of our industry has been written
and already the pages turn begin the
next we have the Academy and all the
stars you've seen this evening
we hope you enjoyed the show you'll be
saying many of us in the months a days
to come
dreams of your local theater
tonight the market